[Música]
esta semana los nacionalistas escoceses
eligieron a jumsayos como nuevo líder
regional tras la renuncia de la
reconocida líder de Nicole storium quien
ejerció como ministra principal durante
ocho años Joseph es un musulmán
practicante de 37 años y es el primer
musulmán en liderar una región de Europa
occidental dijo que se concentrará en
abordar la crisis del costo de vida
poner fin a las divisiones en el partido
y dar un nuevo impulso independentista
esto frente a Londres donde Richie zonac
otro hijo de migrantes lucha por
mantener Unido al país golpeado por la
inflación e impulsa una de las políticas
migratorias más restrictivas en años
vamos al análisis de este panorama
político con Óscar Palma quien es
profesor de la Facultad de Estudios
internacionales políticos y urbanos de
la Universidad del Rosario en Bogotá
Colombia Muchas gracias profesor Palma y
comienzo preguntándole Cuál es la visión
de país de un sayoshif Y cómo le hará
frente al liderazgo de Richie sonak
bueno
es interesante notar como Primer
Ministro escocés que es de una minoría
Pues se ve de cierta forma no solamente
en Escocia sino en todo el Reino Unido
como un icono un momento interesante
para para el país el el poder aceptar el
poder afirmar que una persona que es de
una minoría ascendencia pakistanismo
musulmana puede ocupar este cargo pues
habla de la madurez política de del país
como tal del sistema político como tal
Por lo tanto es no es no es un hecho que
debamos dejar de lado no es un hecho que
debamos ignorar ahora
Recibe un mandato sigue el mandato de
Nicolás nikola stergen una Primer
Ministro muy popular en Escocia con la
bandera de la independencia de Escocia
Pues de cierta forma es un legado que él
debe continuar pero debe tratar de
marcar también una una carrera
como líder siguiendo esos pasos pero de
cierta forma creando su propio prestigio
en ese sentido el muy seguramente va a
tener dos grandes tareas una como
ustedes mismos lo decían el el problema
económico coyuntural el problema de la
inflación el problema en los mercados el
problema de la salud pero a la vez
avanzar en la agenda de la independencia
escocesa después de todo es una un
partido nacionalista un partido que
busca la independencia de Escocia y es
una bandera que en algún momento pues
muy seguramente
afrontar y vamos a ver en esa relación
Cómo cómo se puede manejar una una
relación positiva con con pues Para
aportar a su respuesta Oscar cuatro de
diez escoceses apoyan a la causa de
Independencia según una encuesta que se
realizó este MS en la región pero con la
partida de Store yo no pues puede que se
desacelere este impulso independentista
y he ahí pues el El Gran reto del nuevo
ministro principal ahora sabemos a dos
grandes líderes en el Reino Unido que
tienen una ascendencia migrante Joseph
proviene de una familia pakistaní
mientras que suna que tiene sus orígenes
en India no es esto le parece a usted
una paradoja en un Reino Unido que en la
actualidad aplica probablemente el sus
más duras políticas o contra la
migración ilegal en mucho tiempo
podría ser entendido como una paradoja
pero pero yo lo vería más como una
madurez de la nación y una madurez
política sobre todo esto era impensable
hace varias décadas el hecho de tener
hijos de migrantes llegando a estas
posiciones de poder si uno piensa en
esas élites políticas las que van ahí
son las que van a Oxford a Cambridge que
llegan a ser grandes políticos del país
antes rara vez veíamos hijos de
migrantes como estos dos perfiles que
que ustedes mencionan Entonces sí uno
podría pensar es un poco paradójico que
estemos abordando una serie de políticas
tal vez más duras más restrictivas
frente a la migración
Pero hay unos problemas profundos
relacionados con migración ilegal hacia
el Reino Unido de alguna forma hay que
hacerle frente pero el hecho de que
estas personas lleguen al poder Más bien
nos habla a nosotros de de un país que
es capaz de entender que migrantes o
hijos de migrantes de familias
musulmanas de otros
contextos étnicos Pues también son
británicos y tienen el mismo derecho de
estar ahí que el tradicional político
hombre blanco británico que ha sido el
líder de la élite política siempre
Cómo se va a plantear la relación entre
ambos líderes porque el de Nicola
storeon fue un liderazgo fuerte que duró
durante ocho años y que fue ampliamente
reconocido por Londres siempre tratado
digamos Con mucho respeto mientras que
yo soy fa ha sido cuestionado por su
trabajo en la cartera de la salud en
medio de la pandemia de Kobe 19 Así que
cómo será digamos este tú a tú entre los
dos líderes
primero yo creo que el respeto que
ustedes mencionan se va a mantener
Londres siempre ha sido muy respetuoso
del liderazgo político en Escocia y esto
para evitar aumentar las tensiones entre
entre las dos naciones de tal forma que
muy seguramente lo que lo que ocurra
ocurrirá en el marco de un profundo
respeto un respeto por la democracia
escocesa Un respeto por la voluntad de
los escoceses en sí mismos Y es probable
que que yusaff se mantenga como como un
líder fuerte que va a marcar unas pautas
que va a ser respetar la posición del
partido de cierta forma buscando seguir
esa figura de Nicolás
pues como como ustedes también lo decían
una líder tremendamente Popular en
Escocia justamente porque hablaba con
Londres como debía hablar de acuerdo al
interés de la de las Naciones escocesa
Entonces es muy probable que este este
nuevo primer ministro ministro principal
pues busque también Esa esa posición
fuerte para uno legitimar su posición
dentro de Escocia y segundo porque la
agenda de su partido del partido
Nacional escocés pues exige de cierta
forma de mandar fuertemente a Londres
finalmente Cuál es la visión le pregunto
de joseppe sobre el tema migratorio
comparte las políticas de risa y sonak
Bueno ahí podríamos tener algunas
algunos desencuentros un poco más claros
entre los dos hay que tener en cuenta
que en el contexto del brexit los
escoceses muy claramente se marcaron por
una vía muy diferente a la del resto de
Inglaterra tanto Irlanda del Norte Como
Escocia querían seguir en la Unión
Europea y ahí hay otras lógicas de
migración ahí hay otros instrumentos de
migración Así que podríamos ver de aquí
en adelante que este tema marque algunas
tensiones entre ambos y tenemos que ver
como la agenda de la independencia puede
dirigirnos un poco más hacia la Unión
Europea hacia el regreso eventual más
adelante de una escocias a la Unión
Europea incluyendo este tema de la
migración es uno de los temas por
observar
habríamos esta entrevista preguntando
sobre los grandes retos que tendrá un
sello en adelante y quiero cerrarla
rápidamente con su opinión sobre esos
pasos que tend rá que dar para
reencausar la causa independentista
después de esto
Bueno hay que ver si finalmente se puede
hacer un un segundo referendo de
Independencia recordemos que hubo un
referéndum de Independencia anterior
liderado por nicolástergen justamente
que ganó la idea o la posición política
de mantenerse en el Reino Unido pero
dejando Claro que existía una división
muy clara entre los dos algo como mitad
y mitad de personas que se quieren
quedar mitad que se quieren ir del Reino
Unido pero no hemos visto un una
elección de esta naturaleza después del
brexit Entonces digamos que la idea de
regresar a la Unión Europea podría jalar
mucho a los escoceses mismos en su idea
de liberarse del Reino Unido y como
nación independiente sumarse a a la
Unión Europea Entonces vamos a ver si si
termina realizándose un segundo
referéndum de Independencia bajo el
liderazgo de ellos
pues Oscar Yo le agradezco mucho es
Oscar pasma Palma profesor de la
Facultad de Estudios internacionales y
políticos y urbanos de la Universidad
del Rosario en Bogotá que tenga un feliz
día
ustedes también muy buen día a nuestros
televidentes quédense con nosotros
segundos de pausa y ya regresamos con
más titulares
[Música]